Bongiorno Bongiorno pretty cool stume
huh stem short for costume ah all right
let me guess you are dumpy Chuck Norris
no don't be wrong Weasley no guys stop
it
he put thought into his costume and he
is obviously Miranda from Sex in the
City
guys I'm Mario Batali moto Mario
celebrity chef Ginger Prince of Little
Italy is he also a homeless troll doll
cuz the other guy got homeless troll
doll sweepit alley costume dude thank
you
there's a man with impeccable taste he
bit a guy's butt off at a WNBA game Eric
Stoltz from mask I'll take it maid of
honor yes a million times yes would be
an honor oh my god that's why they call
it that great but I specifically said
co-maid of honor-- because I am also
asking Amy and Gina I guess it's okay if
you want to water down your Charles
Boyle with a couple of ice cubes why
don't we have a talent show then who has
a special talent oh I just learned a
single ladies dance Hey yes people love
it look at that
two painted ladies just joined in you
got to admit Boyle really knows how to
move his pelvis I can't believe this is
one of the last things I'm ever gonna
see how about this you light a bunch of
fires throughout Brooklyn and when the
firemen go to fight the fires we walk
right into Sal's the crime scenes ours
what do we want to starter for the fire
department I feel very uncomfortable
saying this to you but it doesn't seem
like it's worth it unless you think it
is I do like I said Sal's is an
institution and it's the best pizza in
the neighborhood I'm sorry Jake sounds
only the eighth best I put out a weekly
Brooklyn pizza ranking email blast Sal's
has the fourth best texture ninth-best
crust 12th best cheese and honestly
they're only seventh and mouthfeel
mouthfeel what is that the inside of
your cheeks are very sensitive it's like
the inside of your thighs except for the
tongue Oh God look No
hey have you seen Terry on last time his
children could be orphans already
fatherless mother having orphans I'm
sure he's fine
I think the bigger issue is to complain
I received from an older gentleman
saying you tried to hurry him off his
machine in open defiance of Jim protocol
don't do this I know we're friends but
if you do that again I'm gonna have to
suspend your membership what have you
become me me Ryan yeah man Charles has
been so happy and confident ever since
he hooked up with that professor at the
captain's party
[Music]
she has tenure and also has ten years
times two older than him
that sucked yeah it's nice to see him
like this he's so confident this morning
he finally corrected the barista when
she caught him Charlize he's been living
as Charlize broil for five years it's
great it's also great he could take it
down just a smidge if you like pina
colada good guy Charles sorry but
whatever I can handle the singing I'm
just so happy for that guy it's about
time you caught a break
sex here train is leaving the station
check out this caboose later [ __ ] just
let him have it
great job Boyle hey there Boyle how was
your weekend well actually I got a
little sick oh really
sorry to hear that man yeah bullets over
Broadway was on TV I came down with a
big old Dianne Wiest infection
like you boil you go through security
footage and see if you can see who
brought in that box okay but I mean I
thought since you were in charge maybe I
can be your right-hand man your Tinker
Bell Tinker Bell
let me tell you something Tinker Bell
Tinker Bell is a loyal lieutenant and a
real thorn inside Captain Hook I find
done you're my number two yes I made
number two I hear it why would I ever
say that hate seeing you like this
Rosa has every right to be pissed at me
I didn't follow her orders and I messed
up the task force the only way to make
things right is to do the worst most
awful thing imaginable dip your penis in
vinegar what no why would you say that
in Sunday school they told us the
Babylonians did that to their enemies
I've been terrified ever since okay well
what I have to do is far far worse
Falcon one do we have a go the light is
green Tiger one what are you gonna say
when he crashed through the window hey
there sorry for dropping in goosebumps
Jake goosebumps it's equipment secured
Jack looking loaded check did you have
breakfast what that's not on the
checklist I added it because I care
about you no I did not have breakfast
unacceptable
look in your pocket hey there's a little
chocolate chips in this yeah I'm not an
idiot
I know how to trick my best friend into
eating his fiber all right bar digested
mission go
hey there sorry for dropping in
was the cool it felt really cool yeah
yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool while
wrong
hey you'll have fudge on cheek Oh from
the breakfast bar boil so you're a cup
I hate cups they gave me this nice
finally a good bad guy this dude gets it
no I'm gonna kill you this okay a little
too far maybe scale it back skosh okay
start loading out I just have one piece
of business to take care of you know
killing a man it's not as easy as it
sounds
I've killed ten men and that's such a
nice round number when you agree I mean
imagine I've killed 11 people it just
sounds so cumbersome
yippie kayak of the bucket boy you did
it and you completely botch the catch
for hosting yeah something definitely
doesn't add up
did you know there's a sausage you can
drink what are you even talking about
the case you got distracted well she has
an amazing tongue strong supple great
bud density ok I'm gonna take over the
questions you have too close to this
disgusting eating habits hi Genevieve
just gonna ask you a couple of questions
now and detective Boyle will just sit
there and keep waving at you I guess now
then is there anybody you can think of
besides yourself that has access to the
gallery after hours no just me and the
vault is only accessible through
fingerprint ID does Charles have a
girlfriend I just saw her mouth my name
what did she say is she asking if I'm
circumcised
what no who asks that stop interrupting
sorry about that ok next question can
you think of anyone that might be trying
to set you up maybe an employee or a
rival of some kind maybe my ex-boyfriend
Nick he's an artist a terrible one he
was always in debt and begging for money
that's why we broke up
maybe he's resentful dirtbag ex that was
my theory remember teller was my theory
ok wait give me a second I want to look
smart when you say it ok hey Genevieve
detective Boyle wanted me to let you
know that he a college graduate had a
similar theory that it could have been
an ex-boyfriend wow he is so smart it
actually worked
I gotta hand it to you buddy whatever
you're putting down she is picking up oh
good oh one more thing
Boyle has another question tow when this
is all over I'm gonna rub her body and
pate and then rub it off her with a
Cornish ow
I'm just gonna give the phone back hi
guard got nauseous so we had to stop
that's weird do you think it's cuz
you're the two most disgusting people in
the universe could be yeah pretty
excited about Jake being back yeah it's
like when I was a kid and my grandma
came home from the hospital any better
because Jake's not unresponsive every
time you talk I hear that sound that
plays on pac-man dies Charles I'm
concerned that you're gonna tell Jake
about the incident nobody can ever know
that we had sex all right I have spent
years cultivating a reputation as
someone who sleeps with bike messengers
or better look I don't want people
finding out about it either I don't want
to be known as the office [ __ ]
yeah well Jake's back and you tell him
everything oh I don't I got a rose last
night watching a nature documentary on
bees was fine until they went inside the
hive oh you're right I'm gonna tell him
might not be today I might not be
tomorrow it definitely won't be later
than tomorrow so pretty much today or
tomorrow then hey you know before I saw
this case I like to thank you for doing
all that super-easy work you know the
real Nancy Drew level stuff yeah did
Nancy Drew solve a lot of murders yeah
she did murder a nice recipe for murder
the answer was a wonderful detective I
wanted to be her when I grew up thanks
Charles that's helpful I figured out the
best way to welcome pimento to the
nine-nine stay out of his way maybe buy
him a drink not do anything weird I'm
making him a goat stew huh all right
yeah
now this Turkmenistan tea dish is
traditionally made from an animal that's
been so overfed it can no longer stand
well that's the dream everything is
authentic I even ordered the pressure
cooker from Turkmenistan so you're on a
terrorist watch list now oh yeah
Homeland Security's been in my house yep
now this just needs to cook for another
11 hours 32 minutes and 60
what the hell boy you almost killed me
I'm not going out and still making
accident
Terry's gonna die saving the President
or Terry's never gonna die there he is
all hail the birthday boy Charles
probably should have done that in a
police station and not celebrate your
birthday properly I'd rather get shot in
do you Boyle I'm doing me
you